Chris waters I am a fan of video games
yeah yeah I also learnt heard that about
you I like games like FTL mm-hmm and I
used to live in a city called London do
you have a game but perhaps I might want
to play why Daniel I do sunless sea Sun
let's see that's this game about sailing
the vast underground ocean ah that we
have all moved to now that London has
had to flee underground because the
minions of hell ruled the crust of the
earth I something like that and this is
it right here and I'm already freaked
out by what's going on it seems to be a
lot happening here what there's a lot on
screen right have a sauna so it's a it's
a game where you explore this ocean you
have your crew members up here they each
give you different attributes here are
your attributes whenever you're in port
which I am now I'm at Station three I
don't really know what that means but
you have options to sort of pursue story
things like you know so we click here
and I can try to basically station three
if you read about it and Kate involves a
lot of reading does it yeah that's sort
of you know use the art this is like the
extent of the art you're going to see
runs the map the people's faces so you
kind of have to infer the first time I
visited here it's basically just this
iron blockaded station that I have no
access to so I can like try to look at
something inside with my telescopes to
try to figure something out I get a port
report which someone's gonna pay me this
is cool so is like everywhere you doc is
there this sort of unique stuff to not
like particular Island exactly and so
the new unique thing here is the gate
the only way to get past this gate is
with a soothing copper long box I don't
know like if you put yourself in a two
in a coffin you can get in there okay or
you can like try to figure something out
like okay so i can search for signs of
other visitors and it's sixty-eight
percent chance of success sure let's do
that okay i found nothing cool let's get
out of here Wow ok so it's so I'm the
gist I got up this is it's kind of like
something like get Tia we were going
from the porch to pour so much like
you're sort of interacting with ships I
guess and I yeah but there seems to be a
lot more going on in terms of now
when you actually get to those places
the narrative is huge and it's also in
the way you know it's not you have this
entire plaque I'm glancing at this map
well this is the map that I've explored
so far here's where I start in fall in
London and the all these little anchor
spots are different places this is the
mangrove forest where all the scholars
live this is a giant mushroom in the
middle of the ocean dudes go down ger-
Isle of cats there's I love cats yeah
unclear if they're just all pirates or
some of them are cat people who are also
pirates and then there's like the sort
of these black corners I've done a fair
bit of exploring up here in the north
this is like the cannibal Island I think
they made me a cannibal not sure so in
exploration wise that's more akin to
like sid meier's pirates okay but in
terms of all right so when that comes up
someone's trying to mess with me I don't
want to mess with anyone around here no
as there I still have the starter ship
I'm gonna go dark look at that guy yet
so this is their health is two to 10
minus seventy-five gotcha they have 20
crew i have ten their guns are probably
way nastier than mine so i went dark and
i lost them what's what's the combat
like would you just be fighting in this
like screen here yep pretty much that
and you know it sort of comes up here
this is my one deck weapon up came up
again I'm trying to visit trying to
visit the con here but the cons war
trimarans or like I do not want to mess
with these guys I'm just trying to like
trade and be cool so just just be cool
guys she's glory is this another Porsche
yeah so that's like one of the getting a
water world feel of this actually man it
kind of is like this is one of the other
main factions I guess because you have
sort of the London they're one of the
undersea powers the con is another and
so this is like very elaborate I have
like you have to go to the doc here and
they're gonna be pretty suspicious of me
I think so it's a place of stately
isolation here the palaces of the con
and has caught each a fortress 2 itself
sleek lords and ladies and belted robes
and breakfast on balconies an unlikely
antelope pics at you from a park so a
lot of the the writing is really
evocative yeah it's not even like just
exposition
our information it's actually it's quite
like a book yeah yeah it absolutely is
yeah it's sort of setting the stage and
now I can do a bunch of stuff and I
cannot do a bunch stuff I don't have
enough coffee beans to brought to giving
a gift to the con you guys been drinking
too much coffee yeah I'd not down with
the clan of the leopard so I can't go
here but I I have a bunch of drowning
pearls so I'm gonna offer a gift to this
clan and see how that goes i don't know
that's gonna this is based on some sort
of like like a board game or some sort
of narrative that's like pre-existing
yeah it's a browser game oh really right
okay so it's fall in London yeah and you
can go and it's basically just these
sort of choices that I'm making without
any of the sea exploration it takes
place in one city and you sort of figure
out who you are and you know decide what
can't you start off as a certain kind of
person you know you have your origin
story it's like it's like almost like
Skyrim in terms of and then it's just up
to you to visit wherever the hell you
want and make whatever you want so
that's been going fall in London for a
little while and the guys like
kick-started this game they're actually
in based out of London oh cool the kick
started this game and here it is on
Steam and it's a desayunar taxes is
actually this is out yet totally edible
it might it might have been an early
access for like a Kickstarter backers
sectional not exactly sure but it's out
yeah alright so we visited the con I
gained some favor with one of the
factions there I don't know where that's
gonna lead a lot of a lot of this game
as with similarly deep games is kind of
like just kind of do stuff and you
figure it out and so some stuff you know
as you play more stuff sort of clarifies
its meanings so now I like really
understand what these different
attributes writing and how they help me
in certain situations but you know I
have some stuff in my hold here that I
don't really know like what am I gonna
do with a bolt of spider silk I
understand what I can do with my you can
make a web Chris oh yeah that sounds
right I have tales of terror 11 of them
you have tails yeah tails like you
gather stories and you gather reports
and you gather
no all that like a vision of the surface
this is not even a tangible thing it's
just yeah the memory of the surface and
people will buy that off you so that's
another way the game kind of creates
this world is through cool these
currencies that you kind of figure out
so you're here VI can sell like you're
trying not to get involved them in
bottles like taking care yourself is up
is this a roguelike if you die is it
done if i died i am done i have to start
again there is it's not like a pure
roguelike in the sense that your start
from scratch like there are ways to pass
stuff on so like you can pass on a basic
legacy of some of your attributes or one
of your crew members or actually let
chef with the [ __ ] up face oh yeah the
bandage was Sonia or you know you can
your map so I passed on my map once okay
and I've also gotten to the point where
i bought a townhouse in a long london
which allows me to put treasures there
that might answer that the people who
come after me will inherit nice kind of
like a bit of a rogue legacy type thing
yeah so now i'm sailing off into the
blackness i have no idea what God fall
is but we're talking about what does it
look like what does it look like I mean
we passed like lily pads before but they
were right across the street from the
calls of a church or something or
sometimes just occasionally bits of the
roof fall off be glad you weren't here
when this one did okay yeah cuz you're
in a cavern oh wow so this is just a
piece of the cavern roof and now there's
monks you should buy why enough monks if
buckfast has taught me anything it's
that you should always buy why enough
mugs they want to buy wine off me Oh see
I had mushroom wine before going on this
voyage but I sold it to buy more fuel so
unfortunately I can't moisten the
brothers tongue so basically can always
compile a port report okay and people
will pay you for it but I basically
can't do anything else here they don't
have any shops so while you're like
building up your your ship is it mostly
like doing runs between different docs
with like cargo or you like picking up
stuff on the way like heaven how much
run I've just been taking all the really
dangerous recently okay where nothing
really happens except you like going
from port to port so like is that what
you're doing here I'll do a lot of like
random things like this happen oh this
is so this is combat this is maybe not
going to go super great but combat is a
little like because these guys don't
have an aft gun you can get into this
like cheesy death death spiral where
basically if I just chase them around a
bunch and shoot them with my little
peashooter they're not going to hit me
doesn't auto target or is it just yet so
you see it's targeting like it's it's
finding a firing solution yeah and I can
wait until it's a hundred percent to
have a sure hit or I can you fire like
here and this yeah so sometimes that's
worth doing but we're gonna do this it's
combats not like most scintillating part
but again I only have one gun you can
get an apt going on a bigger ship you
can get torpedoes you can have a bunch
of consumable stuff here you can like
fire a flare into this guy that helps
you gain solutions faster I feel like
combat at the early stage of the game I
say early stage I've been playing this
this particular one for like six hours
raised at six hours in yeah I say
comment at early stages but it's like
not as in-depth as it could be because I
don't have their like a lot bigger boats
suck at pirate yeah so that was so what
did we get a cache of curiosities and a
bolt of fabric so let's see what that is
spider silk great that's sure can make
it even bigger than that Wow yeah you
couldn't have just had that mushroom
wine you could have gone back to the
monks so early on you get like what is
that like no no no look at this a skull
yeah that's definitely a skull I'm not
I'm not gonna say all over that Danny
what are those little balls what
something so that's necessarily like a
light buoy and so that's another stat
you have to worry about you meet these
are the things you need to worry about
fuel which I'm actually running low on I
do not want to engage these guys because
I do not have the fuel this isn't
actually not a great idea because I'm
sailing into a place that I have no idea
I should head north report Cecil they
want you sessle yeah they all have fuel
the tides of appetite are freaking me
out
I bet that for people who are playing
the web game for a long time this must
be blowing them they might know some of
this stuff yell or like it's been
referenced like that's what ports essa
looks like yeah right finally oh poor I
know you know you said the tides of
appetite yeah of course I no wonder
everyone speaks about those in freaked
out terms so speaking of freaked out
I've got supplies that's to feed my crew
I've got that fuel to fuel and I have a
terror oh yeah what's that about so
terror is increasing rapidly basically I
can run the light to decrease how much
terror I'm going into your just boating
in the total of dark is your total
darkness oh god no alright so that's a
shark I think it's called a bound shark
because someone has like look some
plates on it if fifty shades grade that
mom oh yeah that's that's that's the
bonded shark you don't want to mess with
cuz like secret like pirates you can do
that stupid circle thing with sea
creatures will just ram into you until
you die that's how my first captain dad
I got killed by a living iceberg a
living ha it's pretty content iceberg it
was not it was it was real cranky that
kind of sounds fun I always think when a
game can kill you in a way that you
found funny or entertaining and that's
always a good sign that's good right and
it's you know of course I don't really
go to the northern climes as much as I
used to because I'm terrified of those
icebergs now supports essel there yes
this is port sessle and so a lot of it
is is sort of understanding the range of
your ships and how far you can go I'm
running with low light so that i accrue
more terror quickly but i use less fuel
because my second captain died like five
miles from London just ran out of fuel
oh no and then I like it's like going
try your luck at a lifeboat like uh all
right and then no ID ID ID ID ID Wow
what happens in targets up to the top uh
so when it gets to about halfway things
start popping up in the middle of the
sea that are like uh you here like all
your crew is having crazy nightmares and
screaming all night long oh my god
breakfast the next morning do you say
anything or do
you just just ignore it because the
captain doesn't deal with that kind of
[ __ ] so cool uh so this is port Cecil
hmm a source lyst silver glow a haven
for players of games that's perfect for
us Chris absolutely Danny uh so I've had
this checkered character rolling with me
okay he's super stood out to get dropped
off here he can already smell the chess
he announces as I'd like some sort of
Sonic's kuma or like it's not a chest
like Bozek yeah so he paid me a hundred
echo which is dollars because that seems
like one loss yeah I was that's it
that's a solid run uh you know it cost
me more to get out here but it's you
like you do these journeys you try to
line up a bunch of stuff to do so i
could play chess let's see how that goes
um so then you like reading this stuff I
don't do that too much right now but
it's talking about like you don't know
how long you've been playing you want to
match another the rough coral tips of
the chess pieces are smeared with Bloods
yours your opponents who both of you
like how have you enjoyed us the writing
in this yeah I really do I you know I
I'm into I like reading you know sci-fi
fantasy stuff that's very evocative of
that sort of paints these worlds that
are other than our own and so taking the
time to read this stuff is one of the
ways that i really get into it one of
the ways it really draws you in so you
can explore and then what happens I
don't know what this it's an auroral
rupture on a rural rupture someone cries
dawn machine waking dawn machine is
something people have mentioned to me
ominously before I have no idea what it
is oh and if there's like a wiki you can
just consult for all or even should you
there is there is a forum and I was kind
of poking around there but I was like
now this is the kind of thing where
exploration and discovery alright so
what should we do I could definitely
keep my eyes off of it I could look
around me but not directly the light or
I could look directly into the light
that's probably not going to go well so
let's look around what do we see oh so
then like you're seeing the colors on
the rocks the water the crystal veins on
the roof like the roof of the cavern is
so often invoked as this ominous
terrifying thing that reminds you to
keep your eyes down but here it's like
something lovely of course I gained five
terror from
well not lovely yeah yeah super good and
go in memory of distant shores Wow ah I
thought that's it is this a pretty good
like approximation of Sun let's see
absolutely yeah I think that you know
the if you sort of what about like
officers and shop sins okay so hold this
is this curio this is stuff that takes
up physical space in my cargo got it
this is stuff that's like you know the
knowledge you yeah so this is recent
news that i can use this is this random
like mummy on in this tomb town gave me
all these quests to fulfill right I
don't know what any of them are I don't
understand any of these words except I
went to gym I went to him he was like
let me see that weeping scar of yours
which i got from horrible nightmares and
cannibalism and that it fulfilled one of
these qualities so it's all this weird
stuff that just creates this really
arcane kind of interesting world this is
sort of how you keep track of where
you've been what you've done what your
objectives are officers each of these
officers occupies a different slot I
cook so much the cook yeah and you can
like talk to him and he's like oh he's
like yeah let's so you can you can spend
secrets with these guys to increase your
various stats or you can invite them to
dinner and then look at as must as much
as poking out of the bandages so good
yeah man so it's like it yes I think
this is a good look it's sort of what
kind of world building it does what kind
of exploration it does and what kind of
fleeing desperately from ships that look
nasty you have to do excellence that's
on let's see it sat on their various
platforms on GOG Humble Bundle steam as
well yeah pc it's like 17 18 bucks
excellent and do you know first we're
reviewing a forgettable we have a review
yes it's coming it's on the way i don't
believe it's posted yet but it's it's
happening awesome well thank you for
watching this episode of Cake swap plays
the review will be up on gamespot com
posthaste but until then I've been done
in wire I'm Chris waters I hope you guys
take take the sunless sea explorer and
send me your horror stories so I don't
feel so bad for all the weird crap that
happens to me good check
you